a lot of people find this really
difficult
you know they might have lost i was
talking to someone yesterday who said oh
you know my
mother died and it just springs it all
back
and we just want some they can talk to a
bit and a few churches have opened yeah
quite a lot from matthews westminster
and paul's common garden in the fields
so martin in the fields um westminster
cathedral
the abbey obviously can't because it's
getting ready for the funeral
and um yeah that's
really really good what would your words
of support be for those who are
reflecting on their own loss when they
come along to pay their respects
i would say
to them
and i've been thinking about this is
everyone grieves in their own way
this may
bring about a sort of resurgence of
grief and that's healthy
it's the mind deep down saying
this is so painful
and
first of all
be with people
second
you know share what you're feeling and
second if you're really really upset
find
someone depending on your faith position
or no faith position find someone you
can trust who you can talk to
and share it and don't carry it alone
that's the main thing don't carry it
away my final thought before i let you
go your memory of her majesty what will
you take with you
lots of things but i suppose i've been
thinking it through
and the thing that's on my mind this
morning is her prayerfulness i was ill
earlier in the year i had pneumonia and
covered and stuff well i thought yeah i
wasn't
on my deathbed but it was
i got a message through from the palace
say the queen was praying for me
i thought
why should she do that
you know
with all her responsibilities and that's
so typical of her and loads of people i
know
she
prayed for the people of aberfan
it's one of the greatest tragedies of
her reign
she prayed for she prays for all sorts
of people she was
a great woman of faith and prayer